hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
directly right here my kid
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
cut through the jargon and make
investing easier with sofi visit
selfie.com omg high to learn how you can
win up to one thousand dollars in stock
when you open an account that's
sofi.com omghi
thanks to our sponsor medterra they
craft trusted effective and accessible
cbd products that support deeper sleep
relaxation and relief go to
m-e-d-t-e-r-r-a-dot-com
o-m-g-h-i and enter code o-m-g-h-i at
checkout for 30 off and free shipping on
your first order
uh from what i can find swamp ass on
urban dictionary at least made its debut
uh in 2002. i heard jim brewer do it let
me see if i can find a long time ago i
think before 2002
jim brewer if you're out there coming to
our podcast
you know jim brewer's
no you could do baseball funny funny
funny
man
ah what brand is that little tequila we
got some cornbread
especially yes
that's great years ago one of the case i
worked on enemies and uh
are you allowed to talk about cases that
you worked on yeah
nothing's going to be the bulls
we went down there and we were in
guadalajara
and matter of fact kiki camarena
he gave us an informant to help us out
and he took us out of the village one
day and they pulled away wait a minute
hang on did you know kiki camarena yes
yes did you know him before he was a
dea agent no i knew him when he was a
dea agent we used him met him on a
personal level then we started working
we did a couple of cases a couple of
things together he was trying to talk to
me last time i saw him about two three
months before he got kidnapped and he
was trying to talk me into leaving the
sheriff's department joining up with the
d.a
and i said sean i think you might have
made a good move there
um
camarena of people that don't know was a
dea agent for the united states who was
working
in mexico or in colombia he was working
in guadalajara
and he got kidnapped by the cartel right
off the street right off the street in
front of the nbc i believe across the
street from the embassy right now how do
i how's the guy that doesn't read know
all that [ __ ] i'm going to wikipedia and
it's like you're reading it off the page
and then you never cease to amaze me
this poor guy
suffered an
insurmountable amount of torture
that
i probably shouldn't say this
was never retaliated by
the usa
against whoever the perpetrators of
torture to an american
citizen but also to an american law
enforcement official a dea
yeah
and uh
if the cartel wants to come after me
i live at uh 7271
no that's ann's house
uh all right i'm just gonna say i'm just
pushing so so
no it's not uh but but but
you know if we did it to one of them
they do it to one of us so
you know i'm not sure what was resolved
i think they found his body and he you
know had a wife and everything i'm sure
we found his they found his body i'm
sure he was a a good guy and just was uh
you know
those guys were those guys were ruthless
they they were brazen took them from
across the street of the american
embassy yeah
they have a uh
it's it's terrible what they did
and
the the united states actually
semi-kidnapped
the doctor that was giving him
medication to keep him alive just so he
could torture him more
and he got released over here because
they
by law they said it was an abduction
so they had to release them over here
and he went back to mexico saying they
couldn't charge with anything
okay so i'll continue sorry to interrupt
you
continue the story
yeah no no no no and then uh oh and then
what were you saying to kate you didn't
get to the case oh the the case so we
went
to uh the place they pulled guns on us
and went back toki i said hey what
stopped them from actually killing the
south they said absolutely nothing you
must be a good bullshitter
and i talked my way out of it next day
we go back and we're looking for this
kid again
but only now i know it's like
going to
they tell me right here in l.a okay
the guy you're looking for is in san
diego so you go down to san diego take
it to an hour drive
you get down there you find him no he's
not here he's actually in san luis
obispo oh no wow so the center point
being guadalajara
so we went out here to the little
village adobe huts everything i mean
campesinos the old flag no electricity
yeah the old like dirt street dirt
living room yeah
and so we come back to guadalajara
and
they said he's over here and take
tequila jalisco
where they have the oldest tequila
factory in the world and it is what they
give the court jose cuervo factory
and so i went there boy this
this tequila jalisco had
a little uh they had roads they had
paved roads they had a church there
and i said okay
the mexicans are into the church
and in the church was the beginning of
guadalupe dressed in an agave plant
i went in and talked to the priest
i said listen padre we went by i know
what house the guy lives in his uncle
says he's over here
i drove by there
there's a relative out there watering
dude damn so
i would be afraid already the priest
said
okay well you you go away come back in
two hours
and
i'll go talk i said he's not going to
he's not going to jail he's in no
trouble we just want to talk to him
please that's all we want to do
the priest goes we go our informant
takes us to the
jose cuervo factory which is right out
right right outside the little town
there
and told them that we were official
government officials
and this was a big show you guys got all
the work
oh they did they we got samples all
along the way everywhere we we got to go
and then when we got done they gave us a
box bottles in it personalized for us
and
time's up so we go back to the priest
and the padre says
he's not here
he's back down in san diego
and i said okay he was in it too huh i
said here's money here's for the church
here's the church thank you very much
you got back in the car foreman says
what do you want to do i said let's go
back to that house he's here the priest
is lying
and so we go back to the house got to
the sister got to the sister she says no
no bottom line she couldn't say because
her mom told her not to say anything at
it
i said go bring your mom
find your mom bring her here right now
no none of them did over there okay
i got to check i know i know
this is tradition
so
the mother comes back i start talking to
the mom i make mom cry my i'm telling
her story mom starts crying
she says okay you
and you alone
can come with me right now when he was
in the house he wasn't in the house he
was up the street behind an alley back
and he wasn't he was exposed he was just
hiding behind he was he was hiding in
somebody's house yeah so
i told my partner the guy's name was
corky johnson who's now deceased from el
monte police department
i said if i'm not back in 30 minutes go
get kiki and bring the army
[ __ ]
30 minutes
so we go i tell the driver
30 minutes but you know what you gave
yourself a lot of time you could have
said if i'm not back in five minutes
because they're not gonna they're gonna
right i think you gave yourself way too
much time i i i gave them
some time to work yeah i needed time to
work my stuff you know so i went down
there went back across the street down
behind houses in the alley
we get to this one one little room pulls
back a curtain there he is sitting down
start talking to the guy explain
everything i want would you ask what'd
you ask him i asked him if he remembered
the date remembered everything happened
and what he had done
he was it was either kill or be killed
he was here in el monte
two guys come up to rob him they pull a
gun they shoot he reaches down he's got
a gun underneath his seat he returns
fire he kills one the other guy runs
so it's self-defense and the guy that
ran away is guilty for the murder
so we want to prosecute we know who he
is we want to prosecute him we need this
guy to identify him and then we'll have
the case
so
he does everything mom believes me now
and everything's good
and she's inviting me back next time you
come back i said i told you i don't want
to take him now
when i come back next time maybe we will
want to take it with us
but we'll pay for everything we'll do
everything we see an informant
he wasn't informed he was a big
information yeah he was a victim in our
case
but only in mexico you know you kill
somebody el que pege paga so
there is no south africa you killed
somebody he thought he was dirty and he
wasn't
okay he he oh oh
so he was using the rules the loss here
not there yeah was using the laws of
mexico
thinking he was guilty
and he wasn't
and so i told mom i said okay
let's just go call the other guys tell
them you know that's off you know i'm
still here i'm alive we go back
mom's hugging me she's crying by the
time we're done
we get in the car and we go back
and we're done we got the information we
needed
he couldn't identify the suspect so it
was
it was no good but we did everything we
could to
to identify them you know we're gonna
have to cut
like 80 of this story
i'm just kidding i'm kidding
i hope not that's just badass
no no i [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] it's a
riveting
that's it you know we went back
and sometimes when i asked you if she
had picked that does you could say yes i
mean you know what are you trying to say
no if you ask me somebody you know we
honestly i was telling pearl's story i
was telling the pearl story the other
day i said the first thing i was talking
about i was talking about my old partner
my female partner
and i said and she knows she knows her
and the first thing he says is as always
does she have big differences
she already knows
you know because i was used to getting
this is how things change i was used to
getting messages
from wives
or girlfriends in the in the 80s and 90s
was like please you know
you know every time you go out with my
husband he comes back he drives we
shouldn't be driving so so after that i
thought every message that i get from
from wives would be bad but actually
they've been good what one day mr you
know mr van halen and mr edward van
halen uh jamie van halen sent me a
message and it said it was in the
morning and it said from j van halen
and i was like oh man here it comes man
like
here it comes you know
you know edward is you know he does he's
he doesn't want to tell you this that
maybe he doesn't want to play golf or
maybe feels a little pressure or
whatever because you know
musicians everybody and she says i can't
tell you how much i love that edward is
out it was always edward that edwards is
out he gets up the night before he lays
his clothes out like anybody who loves
golf or loves anything you know you lay
your clothes on sure and
it's
it was one of the best things i've ever
seen because you know it's like
whatever he did for a living it's just
golfers like you know i'm pl that's why
i'm wearing golf clothes right now i'm
going to play after we get out of here
oh yeah
so it's like like that like you know you
have you have something in common with
somebody
sure that that their wives even
appreciate that here's somebody that and
there's a lot of people that you don't
even have to be famous
but don't leave the house
you know a lot of elderly people too
so what's the number again i got another
one is that everybody call from
yesterday uh we have a couple new
college but nothing oh yeah because
that's an area yeah okay today so
there's a lot of people who spend a lot
of time inside their homes alone whether
it's because they don't have the funds
or they don't have the friends
okay
funds and friends so i think in this
podcast i have a lot of ideas none of
them ever [ __ ] work out but i have a
lot of ideas
so we we're going to start to create a
section called funds and friends if
you're out there and you don't have any
friends
or you don't have any money
that we will have a party twice a year
at stevens steakhouse and we're going to
invite friends and friends but you can't
lie
and say you don't have any friends i'ma
go to your house and smell your house
and if your house smells like pot or
patulo pata zenkulo
you can't that's a combination you
cannot not even febreze [ __ ] on the
on febreze can it says
not effective on patulo
that we will have a party for people who
don't have anywhere to go do you know
that one time this lady in reno i was
doing a show in reno this lady was
gambling by herself and we sat at the
table and i said
are you by yourself and she says it's my
birthday
and i don't have any friends and let me
tell you
yeah
she did and they were hanging low so we
got we we gambled and i took her to the
club this is where my show first started
i was in reno and we danced and we had a
great time and i gave her money after
and she said this is the best birthday i
ever had so nobody should be alone and i
know right now in these times that
people are alone like i'm alone a lot
but
i live in a you know it's a wonderful
house you live in a haunted house i live
in a haunted house but but you know as
long as they leave my guitars alone i'm
all right
and my porn no that point on the
computer
uh um i don't even look at porn that
much anymore when you're vehicle you
can't see you know when you have to put
[ __ ] reading glasses on to look at
your [ __ ] whistles next thing
i'm like who's screaming and it's a dude
i'm like oh
because you're like
huh i put my glasses as a guy getting
rimmed then i'm like that's not the
sound that
that i make when i got real
early 19 [ __ ] hundreds i'm still
stuck on the first line i got rim the
last time i got a rim job was the first
coal mine in west virginia
in 1861 myself
and winston t mcguire
and
i'm sorry brother i got a tattoo of an
arrow on mine and it says exit only
yeah but they have to check to see if
the doors open
all right so what where else were we
that was it
that was it
so part of your job as a as a detective
here
was to go to wherever like you went to
mexico as a detective of los angeles
yeah oh wow you can follow up on the
case wherever it takes you i've had guys
go to
thailand i've had guys go to uh
taipei and who pays for the the the
police department county
sure
so people want to know when we can have
alex villanueva on the show
i'd love to have mon as is
hopefully before june i think well
because june's primary we're almost
there so can you call can you call him
and ask him sure and then i'll call him
but now we'll he he wants to do it by
zoom so we can do it by zoom okay
wherever i am if i'm not here i'll do it
by zoom okay or yeah i'll do it by zoom
because the way my date the way my
schedule is and all the things that i'm
i can't you know because i'm in new york
and atlanta and then here and it doesn't
make sense to come back here but
if we're going to do it by zoom then we
can do it by zoom right yeah if you're
able to do it by zoom we'll 100 and that
hair could cut your hair
my barber
a barber or a stylist uh barber yeah it
looks like a [ __ ] barber cutter
right here thank you
look at that [ __ ] thing that's just
like some
and like some stripes
right now he's reminding me of my
daughter when i'd walk in with a new
pair of shoes she says look dude
don't tell me that's
the other half of buy one get one free
when you bought that pair of shoes
it's not appreciative of you you have
velcro on your shoes yet no no when
there's two straps like little no no i
think they should make shoes for old
people that have velcro that light up so
you can find those [ __ ]
let's say one has dimensions i do have
some i do have a pair of shoes where
they look like they're tied there's no
velcros slip on into them
oh yeah that's that's next that's what's
up yeah that's next
okay
so so um let me ask you a question
with the rising crime after the pandemic
like especially the neighborhood i live
in but i think i think we can easily say
all over the united states or all over
the world i don't know where people
listen to this this podcast
what what can people do
to make themselves feel safer in their
home because a lot of people want guns
but you fired a gun at somebody and a gu
inside a gun's been fired at you not
everybody
has the disposition
everybody can own a gun but not
everybody has a disposition to be able
to be to fire a gun
under a circumstance that they that
they're not familiar with
right that's right if somebody's shaking
your [ __ ] back door and you're inside
and you're a single mother or you're a
dad and you're sleeping or whatever
you're an elderly person
what is their best option at that point
you know it's difficult to say because
number one
in life if you panic you die
so you have to that's true try to remain
calm try to keep track of your your own
senses number one
if it's
you got kids with you then you're going
to do anything you can to protect your
kids
my wife is a
you know she's an introvert she's
peaceful she's everything
don't mess with her kids you know
because like a mama bear she's going to
be all over you do you think that pearl
if you weren't home and somebody was was
rattling the back door you think she's
able to
to defend the home if she's by herself
she'll cower she'll cower she'll hide
she'll do anything because she's in fear
if her kids are with her she's going to
do anything
to protect the kids
but if if not then she's going to be
panic you know you got to she's one of
the ones you got
but it has a does pearl do you know how
to handle a weapon no no she's afraid of
guns and if she dialed 9-1-1 what would
she well not her i don't want to say
that but what would somebody do if that
was happening to somebody who who maybe
maybe maybe you know because it's
usually somebody that's close so let's
say somebody work nights
and that neighborhood or whoever knew
that during the day they most likely
would not be there but maybe they had a
day off and they were sleeping and
somebody comes and tries to break in
their house
what what does that person that's in the
house do you
just try to remain calm question no yeah
hey somebody's in here [ __ ] like
yeah out of here you make noise you know
just like that bear that line you know
make noise
as long as
when people come into your house when
they're doing that what they're
expecting is the element of surprise
when you surprise somebody they're not
prepared for you
but
if you go but if they have a weapon and
you don't it doesn't matter if they go
up if they go up to that door
and they expect nobody there and then
all of a sudden you say
get the [ __ ] out or what do you want i'm
on the phone with the cops yeah
you know they're not going to stick
around they're going to run
they're going to leave you alone so so
so
i don't know are you saying that people
shouldn't arm themselves or are you
saying that
uh
can you fire a shot into your own
like house into the overhead or i won't
say either one because so many doctors
and people
you know they say rapists
okay
you know when richard was raping people
when when this stuff was going on all of
a sudden you see on the news a lot of
self-defense classes you know you got to
do this how to protect yourself how to
stomp on a foot do that show a lady that
they show a lady where the guy has a
clay better guy it's on
and then she makes a move and she bites
the tip of his clay dick off
wow
it makes me want to buy a clay dick
so but but that's what that's what
they're teaching self-defense like if a
guy
sure
puts their dick in your or or or a man
or a woman if somebody
has you and they say suck my dick or
i'll kill you if their dick is in their
mouth i think you have the advantage at
that point yeah but the the problem the
problem is
richard himself said
if they put up a struggle he killed them
if they didn't put up a struggle if they
acquiesced to what he said they lived
so what side of the fence you know
one side's telling you
fight
the other side is telling you
give it up and save yourself yeah and so
you don't know
until you get the guy there at your
house what he or also you could [ __ ]
hide i guess i don't know sure i've
never had anybody in my house but
you know i wouldn't know what to you
know most people aren't prepared for
that even if you come home
and you're with your kids and you say
this door wasn't unlocked when i left
and
there might be somebody in your house so
i'm saying like what happened to my
house yes i have it at my house my wife
called me up when i was at work
said hey
somebody came through the window
somebody's been in our house we haven't
gone inside
and i said well then god damn it call
the cops well i'm calling you i said no
i'm at work
call the local station have them go down
there and
do the police do the police show up if
you we talked about this do the police
show up you call 9-1-1
yeah you know they do yeah
i don't know man because you know
there's so many i mean i don't think
there's enough officers to cover
wherever anybody is
uh you know how they have those those
independent police departments like the
ones that came out during the
during the george floyd thing where the
guys were out with either green outfits
or black outfits with no badges and no
names oh right in bands and putting
people throwing people in the band yeah
those those were
feds i believe at the time that's what
they were alleging somebody who was a
rapper
said to me
send me a message saying
yo man don't be outside or if you know
anybody that's downtown tell them not to
be outside after 10. they were [ __ ]
shooting people and throwing them in a
van they said yeah well
you know i i don't know
during riots you know during tumultuous
times like that
dialing 9-1-1 you may be down
you know somebody else may be needing
emergency help
prioritize over you
but during normal
circumstances and i can't speak for
the los angeles police department
because they seem to have a little
lengthier time response time
sheriff's department still has a good
response time there's still enough and
they still roll so you're saying that
that the la sheriff's department is
better than the lapd i'm not saying
they're better i'm just saying they have
a good response time
well i think that's better
let's say you're a runner and you get to
the finish line before the lapd you have
a better response time than the guy
that's running behind you you just mean
you may have a two goals behind you
no no but do you think that people
because every time people make 911 calls
they always say like hi there's someone
in maybe they should say
my name is george there's somebody in my
[ __ ] house right now it's monday it's
2 30 in the afternoon
i'm afraid and if anything happens to me
i'm calling you to say there's somebody
in my [ __ ] house they're gonna roll
code three i'll tell you that right now
they're gonna they're gonna respond
right now okay so people should do that
instead of being like hi
there's someone please there's someone
in here you should all you should do is
call and tell the truth
and if there's somebody in your house if
you're panic you're sick that that's
something to do i think that's
right grant yeah the person that cuts
your [ __ ] hair next time you say hi
there's a barber in my house i do think
he was on mushrooms i was expecting
talking about mushrooms
all right are we taking phone calls yeah
you need some voicemails yeah what's
liquid death by the way uh is that just
water yeah anybody that that sees this
[ __ ] i think maybe kids let me see the
thing maybe kids have been yelled at by
their parents that say hey don't be
bringing that [ __ ] in this house it's
called liquid dead or what is just is it
carbonated water or just water uh they
have both so this is a carbonated and
with a flavor that's mango chainsaw
which is my favorite uh but they also
have just chainsaw they also have
regular give another shout out to the
gentleman uh are you art at raoul arts
instagram
all right so give me another shout out
give me another shout out put some more
in there he's been putting out some
great stuff
so this guy goes to the angelus forest
and cuts a [ __ ] tree down and does
that robot is destroying the [ __ ]
environment and drawing tambien what a
great guy
is that what he's doing i don't know
where he's getting his wood from yeah i
don't know where he gets to the right
where i'm getting my wood from
big tattoos usually from 70s porn i've
been i i get harder at vintage porn
than i do porn of these what about you
what about you grant
i'm i'm a modern day man i get heart
what about you aaron
oh [ __ ] what about you what about you
he does i get harder at the at the women
from the 70 with real tattoos i have no
tattoos
from the day where you couldn't have an
arrow to your kudos exit only when i was
when when i used to watch corner no girl
they all had their teeth they all didn't
have [ __ ] tattoos
or guys didn't have pecs
peter north about to go shoot from here
to to mcdonald's over there and victory
in burbank and he didn't have any
enhancements just a big fiery
that's all you need i know he does all
the he's doing new dodger stuff
it's just phenomenal stuff i see it on
instagram although i mean is that pencil
he did it with or is that yeah
pencil squirrel droppings no that's
probably pencil yeah yeah
no no it's amazing man it's amazing he
did an amazing job
with all the jargon flying around it can
be hard to figure out how to start
investing getting your money right is
easier with sofi the first investing
platform to offer stocks etfs automated
investing and cryptocurrency too all in
one app i have an account on so fire i
love getting to use it it's a really
simple interface easy to use uh you know
helps me understand the stuff that would
otherwise be difficult to understand and
we're fans of it over here at omg high
whether you're eager to get started with
investing you already know the ropes and
want to diversify your portfolio sofi
has your back there's no commissions on
trading stocks and etfs plus no account
fees or hidden fees
use fractional shares that start as low
as five dollars to buy brand name stocks
even if you don't have a couple of grand
lying around and there's complimentary
financial planners we're ready to help
you with any questions whether you're
stuck on where to start or need help
deciding what to do next and you can
even save for retirement with
traditional roth and scp iras
cut through the jargon and make
investing easier with sofi visit
selfie.com omg high to learn how you can
win up to a thousand dollars in stock
when you open an account that's
sofi.com omghi
brokerage and active investing products
offered through sofi securities llc
member finra sipc
mediterra was founded by a group of
friends passionate about bringing cbd to
those who love it if you haven't heard
of cbd it can promote relaxation sleep
and a slew of other products uh we
really like mediterra here at omg hi
they have a bunch of great products they
have stuff like the hemp infused manuka
cream on the go pain relief roll-on that
helps balance your skin your body your
mind all three
they've got great sweets gummy is for
sleep they're full spectrum deep sleep
gummies are really great at helping you
get that sort of deep restorative sleep
that we all need i hope you're getting
your eight hours in out there and you
know my life is so busy it can be really
hard to just take the time for these
sort of self-care things but medterra
makes it easy so you know we like it we
recommend it to our friends and that's
exactly what we're doing here their
industrial hemp products are grown in
america and is usm authority certified
all products are third party tested
non-gmo and contain organic ingredients
and are grain free omg high listeners
get 30 off and free shipping on their
order with medterra go to medterra.com
omg high and enter code omghi at
checkout that's
medterra.com omg high and enter code
omghi at checkout for 30 off free
shipping
speaking i was watching on tv uh i was
watching one of your concerts uh
yesterday
yeah those are vintage this was uh from
uh i believe it's san antonio
where the guy had a tattoo of you on it
estrada yeah no no he had he had me on
his arm yeah and you said you have one
of eric's throttle on the other one and
he did
no he said he didn't
oh no he didn't and you and you went off
on everything i would [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah tear your arm off them exactly it
was funny but it was it was nice to have
people don't know the eric estrada story
which oh yeah it doesn't matter
uh in 1970 i asked him to shake my hand
he walked by me and since then i've had
i've been dead against him and now it's
whether he dies first or i don't have
you ever met him in real life
yeah and if you want something
i'm ready eric estrada if you're out
there next time i see you we're going to
[ __ ] throw some [ __ ] chicken there
i think you know that and i know that
818 533 1843 come on knock those [ __ ]
veneers right down your [ __ ] god
if somebody saw him at ralph's on
[ __ ] cold water ventura buying day
old bread
[Laughter]
huh you might want to wet it too since
you're not going to have any [ __ ]
dientes when i see you
like a [ __ ] bird throw on headphones
oh yeah no no go ahead uh oh i do you
wanna i don't wanna [ __ ] with my hair we
can translate oh yeah you know
everything you have it on your hair so
why don't i have it on mine
you're not worried about messing your
hair up
how come becca's don't wanna come in
here and like blow us
i don't know i believe we should they
don't do that anymore they don't do that
anymore
well back in the day man if a guy you
know dudes man there was a guy that was
on the radio in san diego and that dude
i think his name was like willie winkle
or some [ __ ]
that dude was blowing every he was
getting blown by everybody my cousins
out there were listening to why 100 or
something and they would just
go over there and blow them and come
home with a t-shirt
all right let's hear it
i think that was his name willy winkler
all right well that i i know where to
start little willy willy or some [ __ ]
hi george this is lisa rivera
big fan of yours and i feel like we have
a lot in common from our childhood to
liking um
true crime and ghost stories i have a
lot of those
uh please give me a call i know i could
change your life
and they always say like people can't
make you happy but i could definitely
not make you sad give me a call
nope
you know what that's not the way to get
to my heart if you want to get to my
heart
or my heart on
i shouldn't say anything because it
never gets hard if you want to get to
the skin tag or my or my heart you have
to leave your measurements i'm old
school
if i if i was an attorney
and they said we have a a a potential
new client and i would say does he have
that and then the guy would say no and i
would say i'm not taking any new client
objection
there you go i'm like the dude you see
that guy uh the vidcon
no on apple about a guy that was an
attorney uh
an attorney in in
north carolina or appalachia or
somewhere and he became a huge huge
attorney and he started to rip off the
social security system you should watch
i think you'd like it
because they have to track them down uh
after it's like four episodes you'll
like it it's called the big con the big
con all right so let's hear another one
that one's a pass by the way okay sorry
not nothing about her just because uh i
can't wait to answer listen listen happy
she won't make it can we hear it again
can we hear it again like that voice is
[ __ ] sad already yeah yeah if you're
trying to get to someone's heart you
have to say hey george my name is lisa
listen
i don't know what you like for breakfast
but i like [ __ ] rim jobs
[Laughter]
all right i don't know if you heard that
from the top yeah i heard that
[Laughter]
now that i had a day of rest i'm
different though yeah you're good you're
good
all right next up
[ __ ] i didn't hear the goddamn beep oh i
like them already
is that you girl call yourself
oh my god
hi
um
energy
but the boy gill
the boy guilt
all right um
so
i love the show i know you have so many
projects going on always
but i just want to know whenever would
you be open to bringing mayan on the
episode or
do you not want to cross those
boundaries even though you do work
together professionally that's probably
my [ __ ] man not too sure
killer um
ryan was on with us one day wouldn't she
was here one day no no you know what man
um
you know what i would not be a po i
would be opposed to bringing my enemy
and the only reason is he would be i
would because because because
of the of the people that i run into and
there was somebody in atlanta that was
helping me that oops there was somebody
where i've been filming
that was with me
that said that
um
they love the show because
it's the freest i think this is the
freest expression that i have in
anything that i do not in the sitcoms
not even in stand-up but for this
genre of podcasts i don't think about
what i'm going to say i just say it
and there's no place in my career where
i do that and i think you and i got
along great
we've always gotten along great and
that's why i think for whatever i don't
ask i never ask even how this show is
doing but i wouldn't bring her in here
because i wouldn't want to expose her to
something that i think that is a little
premature for her like she doesn't need
to be in a place where the criticisms
are higher i don't look at the
criticisms anywhere on any social media
i really don't even look at social media
anymore but you know that the criticisms
when you're not used to getting them are
a little eye-opening because of what
people focus on right sure yeah sure i i
laugh uh at the critics most of them now
because of
my age and where i'm at and what i've
done
and if that's all they've got in their
little world they've never had a [ __ ]
job they've never done this do you want
to you want me to tell you what the
worst
tweet i ever read was what's that yes
somebody said
i [ __ ] hate you so much that i would
go back in a time machine to when your
mom was pregnant and stick a coat hanger
up her
and abort you before you even had a
chance to be born
sign gay boy iglesias
but that was a real one though i don't
know gay breakfast so i don't know when
i don't know if we don't like each other
but you know
that that that is pretty nasty i i've
received some nasty ones like that you
know
uh since i like that
[Laughter]
but i just laugh at him you know i'm
happy where i'm at in my life here's the
here's the thing about that is is that
if you are i mean think about how many
breaths that we get to draw as humans
and if that you're taking time out of
your life
to send something to somebody that you
don't even know
but that you're angry at somebody you
don't even know it's almost like going
into uh
what would i go into a uh
i mean where wouldn't i go
i mean think about some place you
wouldn't go into and say to somebody how
dare you run this place the way you run
it and you've never even
been there or know what it is sure
it's i that's why just laugh yeah you
have to laugh but if you're out there
and you're hating on people or hating on
uh
friends or whatever i mean that's really
more a question for yourself
sure yeah like you know that guy
attacked dave chappelle
the guy that attacked dave chappelle had
like a uh gun knife have you ever seen
that thing no i've never seen i saw it
on the news is that a new thing was it a
gun or a knife it looked like it was
a knife you know in a gun
uh how does it make it simulator nice
simulated you push the button on the
knife
that's what i heard there's a replica
gun that could eject a blade yeah
now why would somebody [ __ ] have that
that's like a [ __ ] novelty [ __ ] it
is it's a novelty but
you can't be busted with a gun
looks like a gun
[Music]
there's there's a difference in holding
you know if you have a loaded weapon
and you have
something that looks like one that's
really a knife there's so there's a
there's a big difference all right well
you know
the the whole
i'm not sure how many times this
happened i guess it only happened twice
because if that happened more times than
we heard about it will smith
hitting chris rock of course
and uh
the guy that attacked chappelle at the
hollywood bowl so
i was on tmz they asked me when i landed
from the place i'm was at
and i said that the hollywood bowl
lacks security i love the hollywood bowl
but
where that guy [ __ ] jumped up was
literally like two feet three feet man
when you're in the front row with the
hollywood bowl you're literally
almost you could reach out and touch
somebody
so that guy first of all [ __ ] hollywood
both security how did that guy get that
into the hollywood ball he didn't throw
it over the fence and meet it on the
other side yeah he had gotten it through
the metal detector so that that's the
bigger question as opposed to why and if
he would want to hurt dave he could have
because he would have had the knife
there it is yeah he oh there you go
he would have had the knife out
instead of just tackling him he could
have stabbed him in the stomach he could
have hurt him you know and he did not so
uh that that's you know a blessing on
that side now now chappelle is saying
he's upset because gascon ain't filing
felony
it went to the city attorney mike fuhrer
because
gascon refused to file a felony so now
it will go to and what do you think it
is is it felony without knowing the
intricate parts how what are the
intricate parts no did he get that blade
open
did he have his hand on it did he rush
him with you and then you have to know
what his intention okay so if he had
that weapon but the blade wasn't out
that's a misdemeanor
yeah
you got to you know there there's got to
be some kind of intent
to show what he intended to do with that
you know just because he has it doesn't
mean he's going to use it
so yeah you have to have uh he did not i
don't think he had it
in his hand i think he still had it in
his possession yeah just possession so i
think that maybe might be it that that
if you have it in tucked in your waist
or whatever but you don't eject the
knife
exactly that so you you and your
intention if it's in your if it's in
your waistband was not to use it because
even if you had it in your hand but the
knife didn't deploy
[ __ ] deploy that that that
were in the army
i was in there i was in the kiss army
and i bought the comic book that had the
blood in it all right where's the next
one all right
oh my god hi
man people that listen to this show are
[ __ ] bat joy arkansas
my question was
um
do you have a bucket list like is there
anything that you haven't done that you
really want to do
um that's not i mean a question for you
and everybody else in the room as well
um you don't know anybody's name i
appreciate you uh
taking the message i hope to hear from
you guys what's that guy's name alan i'm
already sort of like aladdin
he says at the top i forget let's see
oh my god hi
what's up my name is shane um
but i appreciate it so shane on my
bucket list would be
to slow dance with your mom no
does she have big titties
but she might i don't know
um
what's on my bucket list i am and
there's an open question so gail if you
got something too um
um you know uh when i was in dallas uh
the uh
fran god rest is so who was the guitar
tech to paul stanley and kiss
who passed um during the covet thing
asked me if i wanted to introduce kiss
in dallas you wanted the best you got
the best the hottest man in the world
kiss
and i said yes and then right when he
handed the microphone i i [ __ ] went
blank so i handed it back to him but i
think i would like to introduce kids at
a show
because they've been my favorite band in
the world and they're on their end of
the road tour
and i went to paul stanley's 70th
birthday and dave grohl was there who
was awesome and so was taylor hawkins
got god rest his soul it's an
unfortunate loss man
yeah yeah that's that's that's brutal
man that's a brutal loss man for music
so you know for dave it's in two bands
that he you lose a couple of guys oh i
didn't even think about it like that
yeah i mean it's all it's awful man you
know that right you i mean you have guys
that you're with and then one guy leaves
and it's just like it's not never the
same
and you've been there since the
beginning right with the with the foo
fighter yeah so i want to say that that
that uh this guy ernie ariana who
who uh
was uh my first friend my childhood my
first friend
ever
and the guy i named uh ernie valente
after in my first show passed away
um
in
uh kind of like mid-april
yes and uh i was doing
uh man what was i working on that
i was working on something that i
decided to kind of
take something to sleep but most of the
day you know like most of the day and
then my friend arnold called me at like
8 00 p.m and i was really in the middle
of my sleep and said to me that that um
that he had passed like maybe like a
couple hours before that and um
it's uh man i
like you know i
you know i've had a pretty rough life
emotionally
but
i cried like body shaking
thing by myself i i remember i remember
speaking with you shortly there after
your notification
and uh
um
that night uh i think ann came over
and uh we talked a little bit she knew
ernie and then
you know i couldn't sleep and then about
3 30 in the morning
i drove
to back to where i grew up and we went i
went through the streets
through where we had been together and
where we had kind of met each other and
all the stuff like that and and um
man it it um it gives you a
sense of time you know like i don't i
mean it doesn't really matter
how long somebody thinks they're going
to live
it's already maybe predetermined or not
depend on what you believe in but to
lose a friend
who is actually my first friend ever has
been uh incredibly difficult and if you
look at i think it's maybe
maybe associated to my to my ghost
stories but
it there's i've had i've had a lot of
people leave in the last you know seven
years that that
have been very very painful
but i think that um
uh in doing this
it makes you appreciate things because
we do this in the moment this isn't like
recorded and isn't done later that that
it makes me appreciate this more so
so yeah i mean
yeah all right yeah
god bless i'm grateful and i'm godfather
to his son so
i will assume the duty of i remember
getting i remember receiving the phone
call you had been out 3 30 in the
morning tell me you'd driven the streets
and uh
i just wish i'd have been there driving
you around you know
save yourself you know what i wish you
had been there driving me around i i'd
driven anywhere you wanted to go but i
remember you calling me later that
morning and
it was tough it was tough it was tough
for me i felt sorry for you because
you're my uh my friend
anytime anybody hurts intentionally
unintentionally
but anytime your friend hurts you hurt
yeah and so i i was hurting
but you know the thing the thing that
you know he and i had our differences
you know toward the end of our our lives
but you know the thing that i never
thought about until he was gone was that
he was the guy that came to me
and gave me the things that are still in
my life
he was the guy that said
let's get a guitar
and i have a guitar with me this is like
almost
45 years later
he said
there's a guy in kennedy high school
that's doing stand-up that
got written up in kennedy high school in
1979 you and i should go
to the comedy store and you should do
stand-up and we went may 5th 1979
secretary maya was on a saturday anybody
could check it out we went to go see
another thing the first we saw yakov and
tim thommerson and danny mora who i
ended up putting on my show danny moore
became a mentor to me i put him on my tv
show almost 20 years later more than 20
years later and then um he was the one
who had on tv at his house and we went
to go see
richard pryor at his house i didn't have
it in because he was in san fernando i
was in mission hills so he said come
over and let's watch richard pryor live
in long beach so he turned me on richard
pryor
and then he was the one in 1981 that
said let's go golf so i'm golfing later
today so that guy
you know whether he was
around at the end which he wasn't so
much but he had his own life he had his
own
woman in his own life
that guy was with me at a point where he
had his mother and father and he had
sisters and brothers
and i didn't
and that guy
but still my friend
you know what i mean sure
oh [ __ ] that shit's around
it's it's okay brother yeah and
you still got friends yeah but but back
then it's like
i'm alone all the time and that guy
who had all those people
still came to my house that's what i'm
saying that's a friend that's right
that's what i said all right that's a
friend bro that's great what's in this
all right next up that's uh that's all
the time we have this one oh yeah oh
that's awesome that's a good way to end
it thanks for that jordan i wasn't
really crying enough i was [ __ ] here
that's how good actors have seen such a
pro
good all right so yeah keep calling in
leaving voicemails eight one eight five
three three eighteen what are the
voicemails uh the
which one the the the lonely cards club
are our own lonely hearts club what did
we decide oh friends and fun friends and
fun you don't have any friends
right i think yo i think we're gonna see
a lot of [ __ ] people with some
psoriasis after some [ __ ] dry skin
let's have them call in psoriasis
they're going to have dry skin they're
going to be sexually transmitted they're
going to have
diseases i don't give a [ __ ] what it is
let uh let steven know that there might
be some people that have
things you might not be able to wipe off
the table
all right awesome all right thanks
everybody
you